the funniest man in the world just died
norm mcdonald i know there are a lot of
norm mcdonald fans out there i was going
to play a clip from norm today and i
couldn't pick just one i couldn't his
work is so good i've i've read his book
based on a true story three times we've
all watched his videos you know many
many many times you could go down a
youtube rabbit hole and be there for
days
so i did just want to give a little
personal insight
i wish that i could say that norman
mcdonald and i were best friends that
would be incredible but i you know i
unfortunately i can't say that
um
however we we did have a very lengthy
correspondence
a couple of years ago
i noticed when norm mcdonald got onto
twitter
he
followed me i was one of the first
people he followed on twitter and i was
i was really shocked by this and i
thought like i you know i never messaged
him i was so in awe of the guy i didn't
want to
abuse the fact that he was he was
following me and but then one one time
he tweeted something about some pain
that he was in and so i did reach out i
didn't know if he was depressed or
suicidal even now in retrospect we see
he was going through cancer treatments
he he suffered silently privately from
cancer he fought cancer for nine years
didn't tell anyone apparently not even
much of his family
if any of his family
and
so i reached out to him and i said hey
you know if you want to talk about
anything just let me know and this led
to
a weeks and weeks long correspondence
where we would write each other
basically these essays every night these
very long letters every night and it was
mostly on the topic of religion
which you
and i you could never tell if he was
making a joke or something he would
sometimes talk about religion publicly
but he would it would usually be in the
form of a joke he'd say i'm a christian
you know and someone
the other comedian would say you're a
christian he's like yeah you know i
protest military funerals you know yeah
like the westboro church or something
and say okay i don't know if he really
is
all i will say i don't want to reveal
too much about our private
correspondence certainly not not now
but
the thing you noticed about norm
was that he was one of the wisest people
most intelligent people around he would
he would say these things like you know
michael man you're really educated man
you're really intelligent me i'm just an
old chunk of coal you know i'm not
educated at all and he would use some
word that i'd never heard before and you
could tell he had this deep deep
knowledge of literature and history and
philosophy and all of these things and
we we got into this very serious
conversation about religion and the one
comfort that i and the reason i even
mentioned this today is comfort for all
the many many fans he had out there
i am quite certain that he had obviously
profound humility
and a deep
and abiding faith i am quite certain of
that
and obviously a great deal of fortitude
which is another virtue which is really
missing in our culture today when was
the last time someone suffered privately
and died privately and didn't make a big
spectacle of himself and didn't become a
victim
and just fought his struggles and
carried his cross silently
it's a
horrible loss to the world that he has
gone uh but he remains a great
inspiration to a lot of people and he
left behind a great body of work and i
strongly recommend you all check out his
book based on a true story
cheers to uh norm mcdonald
one of the greats hey hold up before you
go before you go
maybe leave me a comment on youtube
maybe subscribe here but most
importantly this is what i need from you
okay i'm just talking you mono amano
okay eye to eye face to face man-to-man
or woman or whatever
head on over to apple podcast it's your
spotify google play wherever you get
your podcasts type in the michael
knowles show hit that subscribe button
it's very simple just
just kiss it then it it'll download and
then we can avoid some of the uh
censorship that goes on in certain
quarters we'll see you next time
[Music]
you